tous
yannick jadot le candidat écologiste à
la présidentielle de l'an prochain
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir
félicitations pour votre élection avec
un beau score face à michèle rivasi et
merci d'être avec nous donc pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec la lfp
avec les échos et avec radio classique
trois grandes questions vous seront
posées au cours de cette émission
d'abord qu'est l'écologie défendez-vous
jean-francis pécresse vous interrogera
ce sujet deuxième question votre
candidature ajoute t'elle de la division
à gauche un qui n'en n'a déjà pas besoin
donc un péril supplémentaire pour votre
famille la question là vous sera posée
par lucile malandain enfin qui êtes vous
tout simplement yannick jadot
michaël szames s vous aidera tout à
l'heure à vous dévoiler un peu plus
puisque je voyais ce titre du figaro ce
matin l'inconnu jadot vous avez été
choqué et or tp n'est pas du tout non je
sais parfaitement douche part et je suis
assez clair où je veux arriver très
bientôt les cas d'abord avec vous une
question d'actualité
et l'actualité bien sûr c'est le vin est
en ce moment même des américains je n'ai
pas de doute sur le bulletin que vous
glisserez si vous votez y est aux états
unis stein stein bien sûr la candidate
écologiste qui qui fait une campagne
magnifique qui n'apparaît pas dans les
débats
mais kick-ass aussi le le consensus
américain entre les républicains et les
démocrates maintenant il est clair que
le résultat de cette élection ça doit
être l'élimination de donald trump qui
est un danger absolu à la fois je crois
pour les états unis
bien sûr mais aussi pour la planète
entière on adore sa victoire reste
encore une hypothèse bien sûr a su alors
nous parlons une hypothèse il a jugé
notamment durant sa campagne il l'a
répété plusieurs fois que le
réchauffement climatique était un
canular et même une connerie là dit il
vous fait peur bien sûr aussi sur ces
sujets là mais vous savez il est
personne vous avez enough qui est un
sénateur qui d'ailleurs dirige le comité
sur l'environnement et l'énergie au
sénat qui a dit que le réchauffement
climatique c'était un complot que les
écologistes c'était le troisième match
que le giec donc le groupe des
scientifiques
c'était la gestapo vous avez un
représentant au congrès qui lui aussi a
des responsabilités chez les plus
républicains et qui est dit de toute
façon il ne peut pas y avoir d'élévation
du niveau de la mer liée aux
dérèglements climatiques puisque dieu a
promis que le déluge était terminée donc
on a une base climato-sceptiques
extrêmement puissante aux états unis
mais derrière ce climato-scepticisme là
c'est évidemment depuis des années vous
savez le financement des campagnes
américaines ou les lobbys les
entreprises peuvent être extrêmement
présente le charbon le pétrole sont
extrêmement présenter y compris les
entreprises françaises qui financent les
campagnes américaines au congrès comme
au sénat et vous pouvez regarder les
chiffres vous avez areva vous avez angie
qui ont été financés aux états unis des
entreprises bd des candidats l'un des
leurs et aux sceptiques d'accord et on
le sait aussi
hillary clinton est en partie financée
victoire départ va par les entreprises
de ce qu'on appelle donc le secteur où
le lobby pétrolier
elle n'est pas vrai c'est un vrai danger
pour la démocratie bernie sanders mais
ça sert là parce que j'ai toujours
marché comme ça n'a pas toujours marché
comme ça vous avez eu depuis notamment
sous bill clinton à relâchement complet
des systèmes de financement aux états
unis heureusement ces dernières années
avec obama il ya eu plus de transparence
mais on n'a pas cassé ce modèle de
financement qui fait que le congrès
comme la chambre des représentants
l'ensemble du congrès et quand même tenu
par les grands lobbys industrie alors un
mot sur hillary clinton même si vous
votez pas pour elle vous voteriez pas
pour elle vous espérez sa victoire
contre donald traditionnelle n'est pas
une climat sceptiques revendiqué mais
quand même et j'ai vu qu'elle avait
critiqué des organisations comme
greenpeace que vous avez vous même servi
yannick jadot
elle a dénoncé leur incapacité à
discuter qu'est-ce que vous inspire l
écoute et hillary clinton les moi ce que
je trouve terrible aujourd'hui
finalement dans la politique américaine
donald trump est détesté et il est
extrêmement dangereux mais le niveau de
défiance vis-à-vis d'hillary clinton est
terrible cela dit quand même beaucoup
sur la démocratie américaine où les deux
candidats en capacité de gagner sont des
personnes globalement mal aimés ou
détestés par 80% des américains c'est
considérable maintenant je crois que
aller moins penchée sur la question de
l'environnement qu'a pu l'être obama est
quasiment pas parlé pas là quasiment pas
parlé en même temps du fait du succès de
bernie sanders du fait de l'évolution
des partis démocrates du fait de la
présence des syndicats très fort dans la
campagne
c'est à la revue ses positions sur le
libre échange et notamment sur la place
des lobbys pétroliers au sein de ces
accords transatlantique et il va falloir
il va falloir qu'elle ait le même
courage malgré le congrès que obama
d'essayer vous savez aux états unis le
président peut faire des décret passé
par l' agence de protection de
l'environnement et donc de contourner le
congrès c'est ce qui se passe sur le
niveau d'émission des centrales charbon
des choses comme ça il va falloir que
les courages d'accélérer les choses que
les états unis sont quand même très en
retard de ce point de vue un mot pour
qualifier trump
c'est un fou je vais dire je sais ça
s'éteint c'est un fou dangereux je veux
dire quand vous écoutez ses discours
quand vous voyez ce qu'il est capable de
porter comme end dans la politique
américaine
ce qu'il est capable de porter comme
défiance vis à vis de la démocratie
ce qu'il était capable de dire ou de
faire sur les femmes sur les américains
d'origine hispanique notamment c'est
franchement enfin ça serait un faux
voilà ce que tu allais première partie
de l'épreuve a été avec jean francis
pécresse le directeur de la rédaction de
radio classique qui nous rejoint grosses
marges en français bonsoir michel
bonsoir viendront surtout alors vous
nous promettez une écologie exaltante
une écologie pragmatique une écologie
subversives
je vais vous expliquer enfin je voudrais
vous vous expliquer sur ces trois termes
en commençant peut-être par le subversif
quand on voit l'état de notre pays que
ce soit en matière évidemment d'énergie
d'agriculture d'affaissement notre
démocratie de de renforcement des
discriminations je crois que les
françaises et les français savent qu'il
va y avoir des changements profonds à
faire dans la société
trop souvent les responsables politiques
qu'à chaque complexité cache la
complexité le temps des réponses aux
crises que nous traversons être
subversif pour moi c'est affirmer la
radicalité des transformations que nous
avons engagées pour à la fois que notre
avenir ne soit pas assombries par le
dérèglement climatique l'épuisement des
ressources
l'airé l'explosion des maladies
chroniques les extinction des espèces
tout ça fera que si on n'agit pas
l'avenir sera sombre donc être subversif
ses causes et la radicalité des
changements engagés et si je dis que je
vais crédible et pragmatique si je peux
me permettre de poursuivre sans dénigrer
contradictoires et non justement c'est
de fixer un horizon de transformation
mais d'accompagner les françaises et les
français tous les jours dans cette phase
de transformation bon concrètement
qu'est ce que ça veut dire concrètement
que ça veut dire que
wellman rarement quand vous voulez matin
quand vous allez appuyer sur
l'interrupteur pour éclairer chez vous
et bien cette électricité là elle ne
renforce pas le risque nucléaire est
elle ne renforce pas le dérèglement
climatique
elle vient d'énergies renouvelables elle
vient de vos économies d'énergie et donc
dès votre premier geste vous agissez
pour la planète et vous agissez pour des
emplois qui sont situés dans votre
territoire
quand vous allez passer au petit
déjeuner quand vous allez passer au
petit léger vous allez je sais pas ce
que vous petit déjeuner peu importe
imaginons vous preniez des céréales et
une étude très récente de générations
futures cas montré qu'on avait un
cocktail de perturbateurs endocriniens
de pesticides dans ce que vous mangez ce
qui fait que la france est le pays de la
convivialité en matière alimentaire
devient un pays où l'alimentation
devient suspecte est bien là vous
mangerez des choses qui sont aussi
bonnes pour du point de vue du goût pour
la santé et après vous allez prendre un
transport collectif qui eut une voiture
que vous partagez qui sera peu
polluantes qui sera intelligente qui
vous emmènera à votre boulot parce que
l'écologie aura créé du boulot pour vous
à l'échelle des territoires et je peux
accompagner comme ça c'est le monde
rêvant le monde rêvait n'en existe déjà
mais moi ce que je sais que ce soit pour
toutes les françaises et pour tous les
français donc ça c'est pragmatique
exaltant parce que je veux créer de
l'enthousiasmé dans ce pays ce pays est
submergé par les déclinistes par les
artisans du renoncement par les
prêcheurs de haine
moi je veut semer l'espoir je veux faire
une campagne qui montre qu'on a des
ressources extraordinaires dans le pays
des compétences incroyable est que si on
les met en mouvement et que si on laisse
toutes les autres énergies se mettre en
mouvement
notre pays sera riche de son dynamisme
est ce que ça veut dire par exemple que
vous tournez briller le dos à une forme
d'écologie punitive une écologie fiscal
par exemple une copie tandis qu'alizé
non non donc il y aura des mois ce que
je veux faire c'est pas une et que
c'était déjà contre l'écologie punitive
aujourd'hui sur la taxe poids lourds ce
sont les citoyens qui la paye celles qui
sont punis
vous avez remarqué que vous et moi on
est en train de perdre quand on est en
région ile-de-france 20 mois d'espérance
de vie du fait de la pollution de l'air
qui est puni c'est
le l'usager avec son automobile qui paye
lui l'entretien des routes plutôt que
les poids lourds c'est tous ceux qui
veulent se balader en la campagne comme
en ville avec des transports collectifs
qui n'ont pas eu cette taxe poids lourds
pour financer les transports collectifs
mais quand je parle de fiscalité pour
moi le modèle c'est le transfert s'est
pas plus de fiscalité
c'est le transfert de 5 points de pib de
fiscalité travail vers la fiscalité
écolo je la cite réduire la fiscalité
sur le travail c'est agir pour le bien
le travail c'est un bien moins
fiscalisés s'est développé ce bien en
revanche les pollutions les
consommations d'énergie lassus le
gaspillage
il faut ce sont des mots il faut taxer
les pollueurs c'est ça bien sûr mes
contacts - travail et police les voleurs
donc c'est pas plus de fiscalité
c'est un transfert de fiscalité comment
on passe de notre modèle actuel où le
nucléaire assure 75 % de la production
d'énergie électrique à un modèle où on
passerait à quoi 50 % en mai l'ademe la
chanteuse ont fait le week en charge de
ce qu'est sur l'a10 qu'on peut passer au
pied confort renouvelables votre
solution 100 renouvelable à ciel au
besoin à quel horizon à balad m 10 à
l'horizon 2050 c'est un bon horizons
pour être à 100% renouvelable
mais regardez il ya des écologistes tout
qui disent qu'ils affirment manière ex
extrêmement clair et très sérieuse et
très argumenté que cette transition vers
des énergies renouvelables on peut pas
la faire
si on abandonne trop vite notre filière
nucléaire par son voeu beaugrand
nucléaire c'est une énergie propre non
pas l n'avons pas de co2 elle et elle
aimait aller mais elle aimait quand même
du co2 parce que vous avez ainsi que de
production et regardez regardez la
situation du nucléaire dans le pays
on a aujourd'hui du fait de notre
obsession du nucléaire du fait de du
fait que donnant une telle concentration
de l'origine de notre électricité
regardez on a plein de réacteurs qui
sont en difficulté sont à l'heure où les
incidents sont en train de se multiplier
notre addiction au nucléaire la preuve
et on saura les rangs les met en place
et libérale pari-cnrc bien la preuve
aujourd'hui une énergie propre
c'est bien la preuve qu'il faut
construire
ce remplacement j'avais dit qu'on allait
fermer les centrales nucléaire demain
bien sûr qu'il va falloir qu'un frein
peut investir aussi pour répondre aux
exigences de l'autorité de sur-mesure au
pouvoir mais alors un les exigences de
sûreté nucléaire bien sûr mais on est
quand même regarder la situation d'edf
37 milliards de dette
un mur d'investissement d'au moins 100
milliards selon la cour des comptes
vous avez un engagement de près de 20
milliards sur hinkley point qui les
opèrent en grande bretagne vous avez les
déchets que rien que le site de bure
envisagée pour l'enfouissement que nous
dénonçons c'est au moins 30 milliards et
edf a osé monsieur lévy a osé dire le
démantèlement c'est pas pour ce siècle
edf existe depuis 60 ans le nucléaire
c'est 40 ans et monsieur lévy dit ah bah
non c'est le 22ème siècle où on
commencera à agir pour le démantèlement
parce qu'on peut pas le financer est-ce
qu'on peut pas faire comme les autres
pays intelligent qui est d'investir
massivement sur les énergies
renouvelables
aujourd'hui comme vous le savez le
photovoltaïque l'éolien terrestre sont
des énergies qui sont plus compétitives
beaucoup plus compétitifs que le
nucléaire est à chaque fois que vous
investissez un euro dans ces énergies là
vous créer trois à quatre fois plus
d'emplois que dans le nucléaire
c'est ce que font les autres et pourquoi
ce nom serait pardon et qui sont
instables par définition puisque on n'a
pas devant tout le temps et qu'on n'a
pas le suis d'accord mais on n'a pas
parlé qu'on a un réseau euros à rien
qu'elles sont transparents 903
recommence on a un réseau en europe et
un juge répond on à un réseau européen
d'électricité le leb la base y compris
des énergies renouvelables en france et
l'hydraulique
ça n'est pas intermittents c'est la
biomasse ça n'est pas intermittents si
on développe les énergies marines ça
n'est pas intermittents et quand vous
avez un réseau européen
vous avez entre les grands ce que ce que
font les grands pays modernes ceux où la
situation économique est bien meilleure
ou la situation du chômage est bien
meilleure la méforme de léonard bien sûr
l'allemagne par simplement le même tous
les pays nordiques sont sur le
regroupement la lutte ils font de
l'éolien offshore
c'est très peu intermittents vous faites
du solaire qui est de plus en plus
efficace et on vous avez des sociétés à
grenoble qui sont recorman du monde de
l'efficacité du photovoltaïque
utopie on vous écoute 999 % de leur
production trouve en dehors de cette
transition énergétique la feuille de
route que s'était fixé le gouvernement
en 2012 elle traîne elle est trop long
comme les objectifs n'ont pas été
atteints
ben oui parce qu'il ya un langage et sa
naïm ça reste un bas alors que qu'il
faut fermer un coup d'oeil aux rites et
fessenheim a pressé budget le tricastin
faut que vous avez des centrales qui
sont extrêmement en difficulté à g et
combien vous habite à son l'accord qu'on
avait passé et le le cheminement de le
cheminent en aide à le cheminement s'il
faut fermer 25 réacteurs d'ici 2025
valable acteurs et bien sûr précédent à
thiais mais que la moitié cc mais c'est
l'engagement de françois hollande
la feuille de route 50% d'électricité
d'origine
si si c'est le sait ce qui est sorti du
débat public sur la loi de transition en
hd le problème c'est que vous regardez
pas 25 centrales jeudi 25 réacteurs avec
un créateur mais pour m j'ai dit vingt
ans si je suis le problème c'est que ce
qui est sorti le 27 octobre la feuille
de route du gouvernement sur la
planification pluriannuelle de l'énergie
ne traduis absolument pas en actes
l'engagement du président la république
donc on est on un pays qui a lutté au
niveau européen pour casser la dynamique
des énergies renouvelables justement
pour défendre son nucléaire avec la
grande bretagne et qui en france ne
traduit pas dans les faits même
l'engagement du président de la
république
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a quelques
soucis avec ce gouvernement sur un
chantier encore une fois l'allemagne ces
quatre cent mille emplois sur les
énergies renouvelables
est ce qu'on peut se payer le luxe de ne
pas créer c'est encore là surtout nos
territoires autre chantier celui de
l'aéroport de notre dame des ventes
alors il y à une décision de justice qui
est attendu je vous propose d'écouter ce
que disait nicolas sarkozy ce matin sur
cette antenne
sur public sénat à propos de ce sujet on
l'écouté vous réagissez
il ya eu surtout un référendum est pour
moi le référendum c'est capital un
référendum cali il faut faire de cet
aéroport
donc je ne sais pas ce que représente
cette population qui occupe en toute
illégalité
plusieurs dizaines d'hectares dans la
région pays de la loire
je demanderai immédiatement l'expulsion
de ces gens dont une partie
appartiennent à l'it l'extrême gauche
étrangères dont l'autre partie réside là
on se demande de quoi est vif je peux
vous mettre sur une piste
ils vivent de subventions payées avec
les cotisations des gens qui travaillent
on parle de vos amis ils disent
n'importe quoi
les années veut une grande partie de
ceux qui vivent sur place cultivent la
terre sont implantés sur la terre et
travaillent vivent du travail de la
terre donc monsieur sarkozy j'imagine
qu'il est il n'est pas totalement
bienvenus enfin s'il veut venir il sera
pas il sera évidemment protégés bien etc
voir venir mais vous avez vu des
policiers dans chaque foyer dans
témoignages vous avez des présidents
mais donnez-moi montrez moi une image de
policiers d'agen de briser l'élan qu on
n'arrête pas de vous êtes vous animé
cette émission vous êtes journaliste
vous me dites il ya des policiers qui
ont été lynchées nos crèmes des langues
donnez moi une image d'un policier
lynché notre dame des landes
non mais là ce que je sais c'est qu'il
ya deux ans ce que je sais c'est qu'il
ya deux ans c'est un militant écologiste
qui a été tué et une zone à 6,26 fils et
même une zone où je deviens télévision
ne vont même pas parce qu'ils se sont
dit on y va
j'y suis j'y suis allé est ce que vous
êtes yannick jadot simplement moi j'ai
fait partie du jeu fait partie du comité
national de transition écologique c'est
l'instance de dialogue environnemental
installé par ce gouvernement il ya le
medef il ya l'association des maires de
france l'association des régions de
france les parlementaires les
associations donc et l'état
quand cette consultation locale a été
proposée par manuel valls études à
l'unanimité à l'unanimité on a dit non
les pros aéroports comme les anti opa à
l'unanimité le projet de consultations
locales proposée par manuel valls a été
rejeté par le commission l'accueil
comité national de transition écologique
ce qui se passe maintenant à nantes
c'est ce que nous disons depuis des
années ce que va traiter le tribunal le
tribunal a misé le tribunal de grande
instance
c'est de dire est ce qu a dit le
rapporteur la rapporteur public
c'est ce l'ailé les arrêté
d'autorisation des travaux sont
incompatibles avec la loi loi sur l'eau
loi sur les espèces protégées et ce
qu'elle a dit ce que nous disons depuis
le début de cette lutte elle dit il est
inconcevable que ce projet que
l'alternative est une obligation ya la
légalité qui va peut être être
contestées si ldc légitimité c'est celle
d'un référendum local mais je viens de
vous dire que la consultation
vous le savez on nous l'avons dénoncée
au jour 1 de la consultation
je vous ai dit que même les pros
aéroport notre dame des landes dans le
cadre du dialogue environnemental ce qui
doit justement décidé de ce type de
processus elle avait rejeté à
l'unanimité la mad men en europe
ecologie les verts mais on a toujours
dit que on a toujours dit que cette
situation va faire était biaisé dès le
départ vous comptez c'est la raison vous
savez qu'on a contesté la question on
avait en même temps quand même
c'est quand même le bazar on avait en
même temps madame royal qui commanditait
un rapport qui disait comme la
rapporteur public travaillons sur
l'aéroport actuel dernière lorsque vous
voyez que dans un livre de confidences
françois hollande lui-même dit qu'il
pense que cet aéroport ne se fera pas ce
serait bien qu'ils le disent une fois
bien qu'il une fois qu'une fois devant
vous et moi en tant que citoyens
intelligents on essaye de l'être plutôt
que de parler à des journalistes et de
dire inverse quand il passe c'est en vo
médias que y profite je l'espère de la
décision de justice pour mettre fin à
cette histoire absurde qui n'a que trop
duré thion est ce que sur ces questions
écologiques et environnementales est ce
que vous voyez en france l'équivalent
d'un donald trump et je suis très
inquiet que le parti
les républicains quand j'ai entendu les
déclarations de luc chatel de ce que
fait évoqué dans sa région et de ce
qu'il dit de nicolas sarkozy devienne à
l'image du pis en pologne et des
républicains aux états unis
devienne un parti anti écolo s'est pas
seulement un parti qui arrête de parler
de la protection de l'environnement
je suis très inquiet et je regrette
profondément sarkozy avait fait un gros
coup avec avec le grenelle pour
l'intérêt que vous les traitez pas de
fous tout à l'heure comme donald trump
non attendez quand même une différence
d'accord est quand même assez noté bord
je regrette profondément mais aussi
inquiet je suis très inquiet par
l'évolution des républicains sur ce
sujet très bien merci
jean-francis voit la deuxième partie de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant avec
lucile malanda notre consoeur de l'
agence france presse qui nous rejoint il
est prof du d'éviter un déclin bonsoir
l'ue c'est lé mont saint-michel bon
seulement des ados alors la question
qu'on voulait vous vous posez plus peu
plus politique
c est ce que votre candidature qui
décide et depuis hier soir ne rajoute t
elle pas un peu plus encore de division
à gauche je crois pas est ce que je vois
aujourd'hui de ce qui se passe au sein
du parti socialiste profondément fait ne
m'intéresse pas on a à droite on en
parlait les règlements de comptes du
sarkozysme on a à gauche
les règlements de comptes du hollandisme
donc ils sont tous en train de s'étriper
sur ce quinquennat
ce qu'ils ont fait au début ce qu'ils
n'ont pas fait moi je veux parler aux
françaises et aux français de leur vie
quotidienne de l'avenir de leur planète
et de leur avenir
donc on que le savez même en 2000 on
part toujours du 20 heures du 21 avril
2011 après lionel jospin quand il a été
interrogé sur la division de la gauche
il avait eu cette phrase qui est de dire
oui évidemment taubira tout ça c'était
pas une bonne idée de l'avoir poussée
elle candidate parce qu'il n'a pas
empêché d'être candidate
mais il a dit il y avait une candidature
qui était légitime c'est celle des
écologistes parce que le projet
écologiste n'est pas le projet
socialiste
donc ça veut en 2012 la gauche les
choses ont évolué ça fait quand même une
quinzaine d'années et 2002 oui et la
dernière fois vous aviez passé un accord
avec les socialistes
certes vous n'en avez pas et aussi
beaucoup de satisfaction c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire beaucoup de nuls pour
autant ça vous a d'abord aidé à voir un
groupe à l'assemblée et au sénat
et est ce que est ce que tous les
socialistes sont à mettre dans la même
dans le même temps moi je moi je parle
je parle du parti socialiste et de la
politique je vous aviez passé bien sûr
je parle du parti socialiste parle de ce
gouvernement
je quitte le parti socialiste qui
officiellement soutient ce gouvernement
et ce gouvernement qui est piloté par un
premier ministre et sous la haute
direction d'un président de la
république donc je vois la politique lui
même
en 2012 la gauche avec les écologistes
présents à tous les 1er tour avait les
villes les départements les régions
l'assemblée le sénat la présidence est
donc le gouvernement
depuis c'est défaite après défaite ce ne
sont pas les écologistes qui sont
responsables de cette défaite c'est la
politique qui a été menée qui est
responsable et en même temps ils ne
restent pas certains socialistes qui
serait peut-être plus frais que bible
mais ils sont fréquentables mais qui
rejoignent ma candidature je les
accueille avec un immense plaisir ce que
je sais qu'il ya plein de socialistes
diront leurs câbles inverse
oui mais non malheureux l'egypte à la
moi je suis j'ai été désignée par la
primaire et que des écologistes
je suis pas là moi pour sauver
l'appareil du parti socialiste vient
quand même je me souviens c'était payé
au début de l'année
yannick jadot vous aviez d'ailleurs bien
sûr pétition dans libération avec
d'autres réclament et bien sûr de la
gauche
et bien aujourd'hui de zico de la gauche
et des écologistes est aujourd'hui la
socialiste aurélie filipetti et bien
vous propose de vous joindre justement à
cette primaire c'est et vendredi c'était
vendredi dernier sur public sénat
j'aimerais que le futur candidat des
verts participent à la primaire de la
gauche parce que ça nous enrichirait et
notamment sur les questions
environnementales on a absolument besoin
et aussi bien michèle rivasi que yannick
jadot sont des experts en matière
environnementale bah moi je pense que la
gauche allait forte oui quand elle et
quand elle est rassemblé dans sa
diversité
ça veut dire pas d'union au forceps ça
veut dire le respect des sensibilités
des uns et des autres et surtout de la
place pour leurs idées on respectera
votre sensibilité
oui enfin je voudrais c'est que je pense
que l'écologie sortira de cette primaire
parce qu'il y aura des candidats qui se
disent écologistes dans cette primaire
elle sortira de cette primaire aussi
essorer qu'elle l'est dans ce
gouvernement quand j'ai fait le pouvoir
alors là c'est une attaque d'agréer
madame monsieur d'origine juive jusqu'au
bout mais il abat part exactement pas
est en effet papa on n'a pas la même
idée de la stratégie politique des
combats à mener à des conversions et
l'engagement dès qu'il a il a des
convictions et d engagement simplement
aujourd'hui soutient un gouvernement qui
tous les jours tourne le dos à
l'écologie donc je m'interroge sur la
force de ses convictions par rapport à
ça mais sur la question qui était posée
quand j'ai défendu la primaires de toute
la gauche et des écologistes
l'idée c'était qu'il ya un grand débat
citoyen que de ce grand débat citoyen
nes un socle commun de réponse aux
problèmes des français et que lié à
l'issue de cette primaire des contrats
de gouvernement entre les différentes
sensibilités
hélas la primaire qui est une partie
primaires du parti socialiste
à la façon de 2011 va sortir un candidat
qui aujourd'hui alors peut-être ce sera
hollande peut-être ce sera mon amour
j'en sais rien du tout de leur histoire
est ce que ça veut dire et stablement
trop tard donc mais écoutez écoutez
arnaud montebourg il ya encore une
semaine ils soutenaient notre dame des
landes est dit il faut faire
immédiatement l'aéroport il soutient
nucléaire il soutient le diesel
je n'ai pas vu macron je sais pas si les
participants je vois hollande valls ou
tous les autres qui potentiellement y
participent
soutenir l'agriculture la plus intensive
désolé ce n'est pas le logiciel écolo la
démarche du parti communiste de tia
laurent qui a fait un grand débat qui a
organisé un grand questionnaire et qui
aujourd'hui présente une plateforme de
propositions serait il vous a pas
échappé qu'on a des différences forte
avec le parti communiste jean luc
mélenchon alors lui alors écologistes
que vous je suis pas là pour sauver les
appareils politiques de gauche qui sont
aujourd'hui en grande difficulté mais je
suis là pour porter un projet écologiste
vous êtes pour donner du sens et de la
cohérence à la politique dans ce pays
donc je veux pas jouer des accords
d'appareil pour un moment se dire c'est
le sauve-qui-peut généralisé et comment
on va tirer notre épingle
est ce que si vous voulez pas vous
retirer à leur profit est ce que par
exemple pour les servir de trait d'union
de dénominateur commun est ce qu'il ya
encore quelque chose
les fans aient joué allés fracturer et
donc moi je veux je veux pas construire
des alliances sur des logiques
d'appareil
je veux réconcilier les françaises et
les français au sur la politique autour
du projet écologiste
je veux leur redonner espoir au tour du
projet écologiste et vous me parliez de
jean-luc mélenchon
évidemment il a progressé sur la
question environnementale c'est
incontestable mais moi et le
nationalisme et l'étatisme pour moi sont
des réponses incompatible avec la mise
en oeuvre des bonnes solutions moi je
veux renforcer le pouvoir des
toi et moi je combats toutes les
dictatures je considère pas un moment
que poutine est plus sympa que obama
parce que je suis anti américain je
pense que le coeur du projet écologiste
c'est la démocratie et que là dessus on
a quelques divergences ça vous a pas
échappé alors l ego semblait
effectivement irréconciliables selon le
matin jean parrot parti de gauche qui
sont des gens très sympa très engagé et
tout ça même le candidat jean luc
mélenchon a plein de qualités qui
parlait d'un gauche en général cela vous
êtes très sévère depuis un moment mais
maintenant on va être sévère avec europe
ecologie les verts sont passés alors
voilà un parti exemple qu'à plus
d'argent qui a perdu la moitié de ses
militants ses cinq dernières années la
faute notamment à l'un d'entre vous
vendez votre fric et encore il ya peu
jean vincent placé ses seules
accusations de michèle rivasi qui a fait
cette déclaration et qui a fait campagne
contre euro et qui vous soutient tout à
fait loyalement désormais à l'intérieur
de notre parti a des gens qui ont plutôt
privilégier leur carrière personnelle
leurs ambitions personnelles mais les
gens reconnaîtront leurs petits en
quelque sorte et que ça soit pas notre
projet qu'a été fédérateur des gens
comme jean vincent placé ou à de rugy
qui ont préféré avoir des postes
ministériels ou emma emmanuelle cosse
qui était notre secrétaire national et
qu'après préféré être ministre
justement des logements plutôt que de
rester dans notre parti pour le
construire les développer alors c'est la
course aux places qui a tué l'écologie
politique j'assure bien sûr qu'il ya eu
un cirque des aventures personnelles au
sein d'europe écologie
ces dernières années et qu'effectivement
notamment les personnes que site
michèle rivasi qui n'a pas fait campagne
contre moi quels sont à vos côtés
voilà un contretemps effectivement ils
ont fait beaucoup de mal
est ce que à l'image de l'écologie
politique et j'en suis toujours
terriblement peiné par ce que je vois
les militants je vois les élus locaux
qui protège notre santé qui protège
l'eau qui met en place et transports
collectifs qui ont fait qui n'a pas de
gaz de schiste dans notre pays qui a pas
de gm et qui se voient souvent un peu
bousculé par l'image qu'on a pu donner
ces dernières années c'est bien
au g7 sortir de ce cirque là c'est pour
ça que je suis une ligne l'écologie
crédible une écologie aimable ni
culpabiliser ni punitive au monde en
discuter tout à l'heure et un peu est-ce
que moi c'est madame cette image cette
image d'un parti donc très fracturée
n'ayant plus de chez des finances très
en forme
cela ne va pas jouer sur votre campagne
en termes de parrainage en termes de
financement quand même évidemment et
enfin peut-être en termes aussi d'
équipe et de réconciliation possible à
l'intérieur
alors il va ce que vous suivez de près
les écologistes vous savez que depuis le
début j'ai rassemblé toutes les
sensibilités de ce mouvement et y reçoit
l'image de toutes les candidats et le
candidat réunit se projetant dans la
campagne
ça fait longtemps que notre mouvement
n'avait pas été aussi rassemblée et unie
parce qu'il sait que sinon il est en
danger et met cette primaire il y avait
plus de votants à l'extérieur d'europe
écologie qu'à l'intérieur des queues de
l'écologie donc ma candidature et la
candidature de l'écologie politique
alors oui ça va être la course aux
parrainages
gilles va falloir travailler très
sérieusement y compris parce qu'une
partie du financement public vous savez
en dépend donc il va falloir travailler
très sérieusement et il va falloir et
c'est pour ça que moi j'ai lancé déjà
une collecte de dons sur avec jade au
point fr pour justement aider à financer
cette campagne parce que et c'est bien
d'avoir une campagne et je la veux
exaltante mais il faut quand même
quelques sous quelques mois pour que ça
puisse se développer ce que
dans ce
dans cette dans cette union que vous
avez montré hier est ce que c'est
excusez moi cécile duflot n'a pas pris
la parole hier soir alors que les autres
candidates malheureuses avait pris la
parole n'était pas là est-ce que vous
lui avez parlé hier soir est ce que
c'est on sait changer s'est échangé des
textos
cécile duflot a du talent on a besoin
d'être dans cette campagne comme on a
besoin de tous deux les figures et des
militants d'europe écologie et beaucoup
à l'extérieur
nicolas hulot et nicolas alors termine
sur cécile duflot est ce qu'elle va
échanger avec nicolas hulot il faut à
vouloir prendre le temps y compris de le
convaincre que cette candidature
écologiste que cette campagne écologiste
et celle qui s'inscrit le plus près dans
sa volonté de réouvrir toutes les portes
de l'écologie politique et de parler à
l'ensemble de la société pas simplement
aux écologistes mais de parler à
l'ensemble de la société pour l'instant
convaincre soutenir officiellement coûté
ça tout ça va mais j'ai été désigné hier
j'ai été désigné hier donnons le temps
au temps très bien alors un chiffre pour
conclure quel est votre ambition sachant
qu'il s'agit de battre le 2d réguler je
les ai un pour cent de 2012 ne dit pas
ça comme ça avec cette voie avec un cinq
ans je voulais dire un peu taquiné joli
e
ce que j'ai dit vous savez en 2009 quand
on a fait aux peco logis on n'a pas dit
on va gagner on va écraser tout le monde
lundi
on frappe 10 plus x quand nicolas hulot
candidats potentiels à l'élection
présidentielle était testée il était à
10 plus et ben moi ça veut dire qu'il ya
il ya un espace politique pour
l'écologie qui au tout dollars de 10%
c'est l'espace politique bâclé je veux
conquérir avec fougue enthousiaste et
déterminé chalet on vous donne encore
l'occasion de vous exprimer pour
convaincre les foules avec maintenant
mais si votre audience avec météo
mickaël szames skis succède à notre ami
lucille
voilà mais qu'est la messe de public
sénat est avec nous saint michel bossi
jadot pour soir monsieur qui êtes vous
monsieur g parce que vous êtes un ancien
de greenpeace à ses vrais part ça vous
êtes quoi aujourd'hui un homme politique
un professionnel de la politique où vous
êtes resté encore un activiste je suis
un homme politique j'assume parfaitement
de ne plus de l'écologie associative je
suis de l'écologie politique
j'ai un mandat de député européen depuis
donc je suis un homme politique je suis
pas un professionnel pour dissiper dans
un professionnel de la politique
non parce que enfin si vous voulez c'est
mon activité principale
donc c'est une forme de profession mais
j'ai eu beaucoup de vies avant celle
d'être député européen
j'ai travaillé au burkina faso j'ai
travaillé au bangladesh
j'ai fait dix ans de solidarité
internationale je travaille dans les
associations comme vous l'avez dit j'ai
dirigé les campagnes de greenpeace
donc je ne suis pas attaché à la
politique plus que ça et donc j'ai
j'adore ce que je fais je me bats pour
ce que je fais mais je ne me sens pas
dépendant de la politique je suis pas
passée je suis pas prêt à passer
n'importe quel compromis pour conserver
un mandat ou pour en obtenir un autre
est ce que quand on a un problème de
notoriété à déficit de notoriété puisque
eva joly elle a capitalisé sur son nom
c'était il ya cinq ans vous avez
capitalisé sur quoi sur la campagne
qu'on va mener sur nos travaux partait
de zéro en quelque sorte une fois vous
êtes taquin non fab ont écouté la
regarder j'ai fait une vidéo sur le ceta
les trois millions de francs à la date 3
millions mais c'est le million
on a deux mille eurent un million mais
temps vous êtes non mais regardez
regardez sur le vol rien de semble
regarder son site de nouveaux bugs 2
millions ça fait plus d'un an qu'il
saurait russe plus plus là à l'instant
même puisque on regarde effectivement
c'était alors un souvenir mémorable 1
pour vous effectivement c'était le 27
octobre dernier lorsque vous avez poussé
ce coup de gueule au parlement européen
donc contre l'accord de libre échange
négocié alors avec le canada on vous
regarde vous parler au nom des salariés
sur le c'est à écouter les salariés ils
ne veulent pas dû c'est à vous prétendez
parler au nom des consommateurs
écoutez les ils ne veulent pas du ceta
les consommateurs vous prétendez parler
au nom des citoyens européens
et qu'est ce que vous leur direz
monsieur juncker quand la commission
fera enfin son boulot sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens et que
bailleur et monsanto ferons condamner
l'europe pour les mesures prises qu'est
ce que vous direz mais ce test aux
citoyens européens
quand l'europe refera son boulot de
leadership sur le climat et que ce sont
les firmes canadiennes des sables
bitumineux et du pétrole et des gaz de
schiste qui attaqueront l'europe alors
avec ce modèle européen que vous portez
de circulation sans entrave des biens
des marchandises des investissements
mais des barbelés des murs et des camps
pour les personnes vous déroulé le tapis
rouge de l'extrême droite et de tous les
nationalismes ayez le courage d'aller
devant la cour européenne de justice sur
le ceta soyez cohérents avec vos propos
aller devant la cour européenne
enfin que vous tenez votre spot de
campagne il va falloir parler d'autre
chose que du ceta mais c'est un sujet
important parce qu'il ils détermineront
la marque aussi c'est le ton bien que 1
des campagnes sur ce tour là on peut pas
faire ça tout le temps là c'est vous
savez c'est une minute si vous faites un
meeting à ce rythme là vous vous heurtez
vous sortez fatigué non mais c2c de la
conviction c'est de la sincérité c'est
vrai il se passe regarder comment la
mondialisation est en train de perturber
l'ensemble de nos sociétés c'est quand
même ça bouscule tout le monde et c'est
vrai que dans cette mondialisation où on
sait plus qui gouverne on sait plus qui
décide c'est l'opacité
c'est quand même une place
extraordinaire pour des firmes
multinationales qui pour le coup ne
servent pas l'environnement au contraire
le détruit vous avez aujourd'hui des
accords qui veulent non pas faire du
libre échange le commerce est déjà très
libre avec le canada avec les états unis
mais qui veulent transférer le pouvoir
de décision de la règle de la norme à
des firmes avec la capacité d'attaquer
des états
c'est totalement dingue de classe
aujourd'hui que vous faites votre cas
que vous formulez d'aller saisir la cour
de vassieux justice européenne est ce
que vous allez passer aux actes parce
que c'est sûr qu'on va vous attendez
mais bien sûr mais écoutez c'est faux
que le parlement la demande le peuple le
parlement wallon qui a résisté longtemps
sur cette affaire là qu'a été due cette
façon un moment un peu le renouveau de
la social démocratie en europe qu'on
n'attendait pas venir de belgique
kadi cette mondialisation libérale
peut-être qu'il faut arrêter les bêtises
de suivre les libéraux et les
conservateurs là dessus bon hollande n'a
pas aidé mais le spd en allemagne ne l'a
pas aidé donc magnette s'est retrouvé
tout seul dans cette affaire mais ce que
dit la cour constitutionnelle allemande
vous savez en allemagne la cour
constitutionnelle c'est au-dessus de la
bible 1 c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement sérieux dit cet accord a
priori est anticonstitutionnelle c'est
ce que disent tous les juristes
européens
c'est le débat qu'on a essayé d'avoir à
l'assemblée nationale et c'est le
gouvernement qui a bloqué ce débat à
l'assemblée nationale donc ce que je dis
j'essaye de porter ça au niveau du
parlement européen et ce serait le
courage de la france de le faire c'est
d'aller devant la cour européenne de
justice pour demander si ce traité est
conforme avec notre âme avec notre sang
sur du sien cet accord faut le rappeler
- enfin le premier ministre je le
soutienne et je regrette tous les
éléments dangereux
je le regrette profondément mais ce que
je leur dis si c'est pas conforme avec
la constitution qu'est ce qu'on fait
bernard cazeneuve qui demande
l'ouverture d'un débat parlementaire sur
ce qu'on appelle le tsc une méga fichier
des données où on aura toutes les
données des français signe d'ouverture
de la part du ministre assez rétro
pédalage à tous les étages
ah bon ah bah écoutez ce truc qu'ils
aient haussé de le faire passer comme ça
et puis vous avez commencé à avoir des
réactions au sein du gouvernement est
faux
reconnaît le maire vous reconnaître la
pugnacité d'accès le maire qui sur ces
sujets là et très bien donc raid sera
glacial ah bah oui si vous voulez on est
quand même dans un système qui est
totalement fou vous avez la ministre en
charge etc y compris qui est très
sensible sur ces questions de libertés
publiques et de vie privée vous avez la
cnil vous avez beaucoup d'intervenants
qui disent c'est totalement dingue de
faire ce fichier là donc il faut arrêter
par des crises à fait ça la cne ne dis
pas que c'est totalement dingue avait un
risque fort sûr que ce que que ces
données privées tombe entre des mains
qui peut être malveillantes
c'est toujours le souci des libertés et
de la vie privée et des libertés
publiques liées à ce type de à ce type
de données donc il faut quand même
toujours rappeler qu'en démocratie ce
sont les citoyens qui contrôle l'état ça
n'est pas l'état qui contrôle les
citoyens comment est-ce que vous
qualifieriez aujourd'hui ce projet ainsi
que c'est une erreur
c'est une erreur évidente puisque moi
tous les experts j'entends je suis pas
un expert du hacking tous les experts
que j'entends nous disent avoir un tel
fichier accessible par autant de
services c'est un système qui assez
rapidement se fera à quai et donc des
données privées seront potentiellement
mal utilisé donc il faut les mettre
c'est ce que vous avez réfléchi à des
actions vous pourriez mener pour lutter
contre ce fichier pour demander sa
suspension par le débat ça va être le
boulot de de l'assemblée notamment qui
va s'emparer je suis candidat à
l'élection présidentielle oui mais moi
je vous dis que je suis contre ce projet
mais je suis contre ce projet donc je
peux pas vous dire plus
maintenant je suis convaincu que nos
élus à l'assemblée au sénat vont faire
le boulot pour essayer de stopper ce
projet franchement après la loi
renseignement après l'état d'urgence
tout ça ça suffit autre sujet des
députés républicains souhaitent faire
destituer le président de la république
après ses propos dans le livre
un président ne devrais pas dire ça je
vous vois soufflé est ce que c'est
quelque chose on n'est pas dans les
faits
si vous voulez je crois que
malheureusement pour lui
et oui pour françois hollande
moi j'ai l'impression de françois
hollande c'est déjà le passé j'ai on a
déjà l'impression qu' il ne gouverne
plus pays que quand il parle au bout
d'une minute et demie vous arrêtez de
l'écouter c'est terrible parce que c'est
le président de la république que il
il ne prend plus en main les grandes
décisions qu'il devait prendre il a
renoncé aux grandes réformes sur
lesquelles il s'est engagé
donc pour moi consolante c'est déjà le
passé c'est déjà le passé
c'est un art vivant comme l'a dit nous y
en a non non non non j'aime pas je
n'aime pas cette expression là je pense
qu'il est temps qu'ils prennent de très
grandes vacances qui selon lui seront
certainement très mérité vous considérez
que sa nouvelle candidature serait une
hérésie ce qu'ils veulent l'histoire du
parti socialiste avait la politique
qu'il a menée la mnef vassaux début de
la mener avec montebourg avec tous les
autres et de la mnef macron qui règle le
maquereau aujourd'hui on a appris qu'il
pourrait très vite être candidat en tout
cas avant le 10 décembre
c'est pas mon logiciel politique mais je
trouve que ce serait un magnifique
adversaires au moins il renouvelle le
paysage politique après c'est un libéral
qui s'assume
je préfère le libéralisme assumé d'un
macron ma libre alice trait à la
française un trait medef quand même à on
en tapas aux rentes du medef donc on
tape or en du nucléaire on tape à oran
de la finance on t'a pas aux rentes du
bon donc je regrette qu'il existe y
voilà mais c'est un libéral qui s'assume
hollande et valls se prétendent des
socialistes mais qu'ils font quand même
plutôt une politique libérale qui
s'assume pas je préfère quelqu'un qui
s'assume qui est nouveau dans le paysage
politique et ce sera encore une fois un
adversaire je crois de talent mais en
tous les cas c'est lui qui aurait pris
le moindre coût de votre part dans cette
émission passé alors qu'est-ce que vous
avez tapé sur la gomme énorme et je te
juger vous savez je suis dans une énorme
frustration je suis dans une énorme
frustration on a un pays qui est au bord
de la rupture et on a un pays qui
pourrait basculer si vite parce que
l'agriculture qui fait du bien elle
existe les citoyens qui veulent protéger
leur santé ils sont déjà sensibilisés
les choix industriels
station qui créent de l'emploi
frustration c'est quoi mais parce que ce
pays ne ne se met pas en mouvement
autour de ses solutions à mars ne se met
pas non parce que sur verre pour un coût
macron sur l'écologie les nus à ouimet
anglais il est nul mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que il ya tellement de force
vitale dans ce pays qui font des choses
magnifiques
si c'était à eux qu'ont laissé l'espace
et non pas ceux qui nous empêchent
d'avancer
ceux qui sont les laits des artisans du
conservatisme du corporatisme de la
rente et du blocage des institutions ce
qu'empêche notre pays mais il il est là
a basculé potentiellement dans une
économie qui avance et dans une société
qui retrouve l'accompagnement vous
n'avez pas parlé d' allah gp qui a eu un
engagement écologique fort grand
dernières années oui ça m'a pas marqué
dans les débats qu'ils ont organisé son
engagement pour l'environnement mais à
la primaire de droite sarkozy juppé vous
votez 2006 une caste ward c'est
l'histoire de la droite et du centre a
pas échappé même si certains électeurs
de gauche
ah mais ça c'est chacun est libre dans
son dans son choix et dans son
engagement
moi je suis candidat à l'élection
présidentielle pour les écologistes mais
rien ne m'échappe et d'avoir été avec
nous merci à j + 1 après votre
désignation de franck munich merci
beaucoup mais quelle bonsoir à tous et
la semaine prochaine c'est le sénateur
bruno retailleau qui sera notre invité
qui est un soutien fidèle lui de france
à ce sera juste après le rendu du
tribunal de nantes à sa position
effectivement sur l'avenir de l'aéroport
sera est évidemment très attendu
également à la semaine prochaine